>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington D.C.
>> Petra Mayer: I'm so excited.
I mean I would have run here
anyways to interview Gene Yang
because he's one of my
favorite comic artists.
But a little bit of
housekeeping before we begin.
Thank you so much everyone
for coming
out to the National Book Festival
today and thank you to the Library
of Congress for continuing
to host this awesome
festival of book nerdery.
I'm Petra Mayer.
In addition to being very out
of breath I am also the editor
of NPR books and we're also media
partners for this year's festival.
I'd also like to thank the festivals
co-chairman David Rubenstein
and all the many sponsors who helped
to make it happen this
year and every year.
Now I'm sure you have
all already done this,
but if you could turn
your cell phones off.
There will be time for
questions afterwards.
Just be aware that if you
do get up to ask a question,
you will be filmed for
the library's archives.
So on to the main event.
I'm so excited to be here
today introducing Gene Yang
like I said one of my favorite --
you've got some fans out there,
one of my favorite comic
and graphic novel creators.
He's done so much cool
stuff that I'm going
to have a little trouble
just cramming it all
into the three minute
introduction they told us to do.
But I'll give it a go.
Gene's graphic novel American
Born Chinese came out in 2006
and won just about every
award there was to win.
It's a lovely book that weaves
together three separate stories
into a funny and profound
meditation on identity belonging
in the Chinese immigrant experience.
Identity and belonging are themes
that come up a lot in Gene's work.
His epic two part graphic novel
Boxers and Saints was a finalist
for the National Book Award 2013.
It's the story of China's
Boxer Rebellion told
from two different perspectives.
A young boy who believes that
China's ods and hero's are fighting
with him against Christian and
western imperial influences
and a girl who converts to
Catholicism after being rejected
by the people around her and
who sees visions of Joan of Arc.
He's a big fan of super hero's too.
After taking on the Boxer Rebellion
he created a back story for one
of the first Asian-American
super hero's the green turtle
in the 2014 graphic novel, novel
-- excuse me The Shadow Hero.
Gene has also spent many
years teaching high school
where he discovered the roll
comics played in education
as a substitute math
teacher he made comics
to explain algebra for his students.
And I believe it was on this
festival stage a couple years ago
that you were called your teacher
saying Mr. Yang you're kind
of boring in person but
we love you in comics."
>> Gene Luen Yang: That's right.
That's exactly right.
>> Petra Mayer: So the Library
of Congress has recognized
Gene's commitment
to education earlier this year when
they named him their ambassador
for young people's literature.
His latest book is Secret Coders
Paths and Portals, which is a part
of a series that teaches kids
basic computer programming.
I'm going to turn the page now.
Basic computer programming concepts
as part of a fun adventure story.
He's also writing and this is
very cool the new superman series
for DC Comics featuring the
Chinese hero Kenan Kong.
Did I say that right?
>> Gene Luen Yang: That's right.
>> Petra Mayer: Okay
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yep.
>> Petra Mayer: And last
but definitely not least,
you may have heard a
couple days ago he's one
of this year's MacArthur
Genius Grants recipients.
So.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Petra Mayer: Please
welcome artist, writer,
and certified super
genius Gene Yang.
Congratulations on the genius grant.
I mean that's amazing.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
Oh it's mind blowing.
I feel like my mind is still numb.
It's a, it's been a shock.
>> Petra Mayer: I'm
trying to resist asking you
if you're going to Disneyland.
But how, how will it affect
your work, do you think?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Well
you know -- I'd so --
I've been thinking about it.
I, I, I found out three weeks ago.
It was one morning I was pulling
out of my driveway to
go to Panera Bread.
I go to Panera Bread to write
because I used to have a studio
at my house, but then my oldest
daughter got too old to share a room
with the other two daughters.
So I had to give up my studio
so she could have a bedroom.
And since then I've just been
struggling to find a place to work.
>> Petra Mayer: Panera Bread
>> Gene Luen Yang: I go to Panera
Bread and then I get a call
from the MacArthur foundation.
They tell me this news and then
I just stayed in my driveway
for like half an hour after that.
I eventually did make it to Panera
Bread but I did not work at all.
>> Petra Mayer: Did you order
something really expensive?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Oh no.
I ordered a cup of coffee because
I was I was half expecting one
of my friends to call me
up and go just kidding.
But that didn't happen.
That didn't happen.
>> Petra Mayer: Okay.
>> Gene Luen Yang: But I've been
thinking about it since then.
And I think -- I see myself as
having three different roles.
I'm a member of a family.
I'm a son, I'm a father
and I'm a husband.
I'm a cartoonist.
And I'm also a teacher.
And specifically I'm a, I'm a
national ambassador for, for,
for these next couple years.
I want to put some of the
resources in each of those roles.
>> Petra Mayer: So
what makes comics --
I mean The, The Library of
Congress recognized your work
with comics and education.
What do you think makes
comics such a good medium
for conveying information to kids?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Well really
I, I mean I think different kinds
of information are conveyed
best in different ways.
And the thing about comics is
that at least in American culture
for decades, and decades,
and decades,
there education potential
just wasn't recognized.
I mean it dates back to the 40's and
50's for really intermental reasons.
I, I don't think comics is
necessarily the best medium
of communication.
It's the one I feel most
like heart attachment too.
But I don't think it's necessarily
the best one I just think it's
another tool in the tool box.
And there're specific
kinds of information
that are best communicated
through comics.
For instance all of you have
seen those instruction packets
that come with Lego sets.
Those are basically comics.
There're sequential images right?
And can you imagine
reading text to tell you how
to put together a, a Lego set.
It would be practically impossible.
And I would even argue that comics
works better than video for that.
Because when you're
watching a video the,
the person making the video isn't
necessarily going at the same rate
as you want to go to
build that Lego set.
So that's just a really,
really simple example.
>> Petra Mayer: I just -- can
I just say will you please
like design IKEA manuals?
That's where my brain went.
Right? [inaudible]
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
Yeah. They poorly, poorly
made comics I would say.
>> Petra Mayer: I read somewhere
that you had a real interesting
comment about how teaching
by comics allows kids
to set the rate
at which they take
in the information.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, I mean they're all
sorts of visual story telling.
There's comics there's
film, there's television.
And out of all the ones that are
out there comics is the only one
that doesn't actually have time.
Time actually doesn't
exist in comics right?
In a page of comics past, present
and future all sit side by side.
And because of that the
reader gets to decide how fast
or slow the information goes
from the page into their brain.
And the same is not true for
animation or, or film or television.
>> Petra Mayer: So tell me a little
bit about what you've been doing.
You were named ambassador
earlier this year
and I think your program
was reading without walls.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yes.
>> Petra Mayer: Tell us about that.
>> Gene Luen Yang: So every
ambassador picks a platform
something that they
want to focus on.
For me I chose reading
without walls.
And by that I mean I want
kids I want everybody really
to explore the world
through reading.
And I want them to explore the world
through reading in
three specific ways.
Number one is I want people to
pick books about people who aren't
like them, who don't look
like them or live like them.
Two I want people to
pick books about topics
that they might find
kind of intimidating.
And three I want people
to pick books in formats
that they don't normally
read for fun.
So normally you read chapter books
for fun I want you to
try a graphic novel.
And normally all you
read is graphic novels
like one of the kids in my home.
I want you to try a, a chapter
book or a, a, book in verse.
I just think there's
so much great stuff
out there in book format you know.
I want everybody to
give everything a try.
>> Petra Mayer: So well let's speak
specifically about Secret Coders
which I picked up the
most recent volume
and I thought oh God I haven't
coded since I was you know
in 9th grade learning logo on an
Apple II and there it was Paths
and Portals with the
little turtle on the front.
>> Gene Luen Yang: That's right.
>> Petra Mayer: I'm sorry.
I got the binary bird.
I figured that part out but so --
why don't you tell us a little bit
about the series and
what it designed to do?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Secret
Coders is a, is a like a,
it's project that I've been
thinking about for a long time.
I taught high school
computer science for 17 years.
I taught in this really visual
way so I do a lot of drawing
on the board and I always thought
a lot of the stuff I was doing
on the board would work really well
in sequential art form
in graphic novel format.
And Secret Coders is basically that.
It's me taking what I
used to do in my classroom
and doing it on the page.
I teamed up with a guy named Mike
Holmes who's incredibly talented.
He worked on the Adventure
Time comic books
and the Bravest Warriors
comic books before he teamed
up with me on, on Secret Coders.
And together we are trying to
teach kids the fundamentals
of computer science through comics.
And again the, the reason why
we want to do this in comics is
because we want to allow
students to take that information
in at the rate that best suits them.
We want them to be able to
reread passages if they need to.
>> Petra Mayer: Yeah I had
to reread a little bit.
It's been a long time since
I was working in logo.
So where did you get the idea?
What made you think hey first
of all learning computer
science is important
and secondly I think comics
are a great way to do that?
>> Gene Luen Yang: It,
it, it dates back to my,
my years in the classroom.
You know when I was -- when I
first took my teaching job I used
to tell students on the
first day of every semester
that I was also a cartoonist.
I was involved in comics
because I thought
that that would make
them think I was cool.
>> Petra Mayer: Did it?
Did it work?
>> Gene Luen Yang: I was wrong.
I was wrong.
>> Petra Mayer: Drat those students.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
They -- well this was
like the 90's right?
So nobody like comics
just didn't have the,
the cache that they do today.
Nobody knew who Iron Man was
let alone like Rocket Raccoon.
>> Petra Mayer: Heathens.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah, so,
so very quickly I realized --
and, and the worst part about it
is after I told them I was involved
in comics, when things
got hard in my class,
they would ask me comic
book related questions.
They would try to get me off track.
They would raise their
hand and go "Mr. Yang,
who do you think would win in
a fight Superman or the Hulk?"
So I feel like I had to keep
these two things separate.
I would, I would teach by
day and make comics at night.
And eventually they came
back together for me
in this Algebra II class.
So one of my colleagues in
the math department had to go
on long term leave I was given
his Algebra II class sub.
I was the long term sub.
But I was also the school
educational technologist at the time
which meant it was my job
to help other teachers work
computer stuff into their curricula.
So what that meant for
this Algebra II class was
that every two weeks I would
have to miss a couple of sessions
because I would be in some
other classroom helping some
other teacher.
So to make up for that I started
video-taping myself giving lectures
and that was horrible.
My students hated it.
They would come up to
me and they would say
"Mr. Yang we thought you
were boring in person
but on video you are
just unbearable."
>> Petra Mayer: That's mean.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah,
well teenagers you know.
>> Petra Mayer: Okay, right.
Still.
>> Gene Luen Yang: And, and,
and as a desperate second attempt
I started drawing these lessons
in comics and I would photocopy
them, I would hand them out to --
I would give them to my sub who
would hand them out to the students.
And these much to my surprise
were, were kind of a hit.
Like they, they preferred
me in cartoon format
to like actual flesh and blood.
So, so that surprised me because I
always thought man the students grow
up with screens that would
prefer to take information
in from a screen than
in from a page.
But I was wrong.
They, they preferred the page
at least in, in comics format.
>> Petra Mayer: So what kind of
feedback have you been getting?
What are people saying
to you about it?
>> Gene Luen Yang: About,
about Secret Coders?
>> Petra Mayer: Secret Coders, yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah,
it, it seems like people,
people are, are kind of into it.
I mean there's a there's a
certain kind of nerd kid that seems
to gravitate towards the series.
And what I'm trying to do, is
I'm trying to get everybody in,
in under the tent of coding right?
Not just the nerd kids.
But I did just get a, a
photo a few months ago
from a mom of a first grader.
And this first grader, in this
photo she was standing at the front
of her class, teaching her
entire class how to read binary.
And that was so gratifying to me.
She was using the method that I
use in Secret Coders Volume I.
>> Petra Mayer: Which are
like these little birds
and they have four eyes.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yes.
>> Petra Mayer: They're
kind of creepy looking.
Are they robot birds?
>> Gene Luen Yang:
They're robot birds.
>> Petra Mayer: Yeah and they --
I didn't quite understand them.
Then there was that thing with
the pennies and the graph.
>> Gene Luen Yang: There
eyes display binary numbers.
Yes.
>> Petra Mayer: I'm sure you
guys will all understand it.
It, it was a revelation to
me, to be perfectly honest.
So there you go, very educational.
I also want to -- but
there's a little bit --
I mean I mention sort of theses
of identity and belonging
and actually what stuck out to
me in the most recent book was,
was that exchange between
Hopper and her mother
about how to do Mandarin homework.
That was so poetic.
Like her mother has
this one approach.
And she has a different one.
>> Gene Luen Yang: That was --
so I do have I do have a scene
in the second book
Hopper the main character,
her mother is the Mandarin
teacher of her school.
And part of Mandarin
homework is they have
to write these characters over,
and over, and over again, right?
And that was actually
was actually a struggle
that I had when I was a kid.
I went to Chinese school every
Saturday for 12 years of my life.
I speak Chinese like a four year
old so it didn't really work for me.
But.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Gene Luen Yang: We had to
write these characters over,
and over, and over again.
And it really felt robotic.
And it wasn't until I became
an adult that I realized
when you practice something
over, and over, and over again,
you're not acting like a robot.
You're actually gaining the skills
to express new ones, you know?
And, and that's kind of what
I wanted in that exchange.
>> Petra Mayer: Yeah it's true
if you're drawing something
in logo there's not a
whole lot of nuance.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Not
a lot of nuance yeah.
>> Petra Mayer: And less repetition.
>> Gene Luen Yang: It's just two
ways of approaching art, right?
There's, there's one -- both
of them I think have a place.
>> Petra Mayer: So we've discussed
education, and, and, and coding,
and, and classroom subjects.
And we've been mature and now
I want to talk about Superman.
Superman is cool.
I feel like we have to maybe
give people a little bit
of a primer though on what's
going on right now in.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Petra Mayer: See universe.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
Because it's super heroes
and super heroes are
always overly complicated.
>> Petra Mayer: Seriously, I
mean it took me so long to get
into just Marvel continuity like I.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Petra Mayer: You know I,
I sort of vaguely understand
the X-Men now but it's a task.
Let me tell you.
>> Gene Luen Yang: I'm
not with you there.
I don't understand the X-Men at all.
>> Petra Mayer: I like them vaguely.
>> Gene Luen Yang: I love
them but I don't understand.
>> Petra Mayer: I can
recommend you a pod cast.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
>> Petra Mayer: After
this conversation.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Awesome.
>> Petra Mayer: So Gene is
writing the new Superman.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Petra Mayer: Do you want to
explain why we need a new Superman.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Because super
hero comics are super complicated.
So this is what happened.
In, in, in the DC universe this
past summer, Clark Kent died
and he was replaced
by three characters.
Number one was another Clark
Kent from a different dimension.
Like I said super heroes.
>> Petra Mayer: Didn't he
already die like once before?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah,
he died once before.
>> Petra Mayer: Okay.
>> Gene Luen Yang: But that was
also in a different dimension.
Say -- anyways.
He was replaced by Clark
Kent from another dimension.
He was replaced by Lois
Lane who becomes Superwoman.
And he's also replaced by a brand
new character Kenan Kong a 17 year
old kid that grew up that --
is growing up in Shanghai who
gets some of Clark Kent's powers.
And that's the, that's the
series that I'm working on.
The third issue of new
Superman just came out about,
about a week and a half ago.
And this was not my idea.
Actually I did not go to DC Comics
and go hey let's make
Superman Chinese.
This is something that
they brought to me.
And, and, and I remember when
they first brought this I was
like that is a terrible idea.
I don't want anything
to do with that.
>> Petra Mayer: Why?
I didn't -- well.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Oh my gosh.
Okay so it's the idea -- from what
I gather it was the idea of Jim Lee
who is the co-publisher
at DC Comics.
He was a fan favorite
artist in the 90's.
He made a name for himself working.
>> Petra Mayer: Sure.
>> Gene Luen Yang: on X-Men.
I collected Jim Lee comics
when I was in high school.
>> Petra Mayer: Did
he found Wildstorm?
>> Gene Luen Yang: I loved him.
Yes and he also found
-- founded Wildstorm.
And then it was also Geoff Johns.
Geoff Johns a super star
-- super hero writer.
He's the president of DC Comics now.
Supposedly they both wanted an
Asian member of the Superman family.
You know? But I did not want to
do that because I just immediately
when I heard that idea I was like
there are so many land mines there.
You know both culturally
and politically.
So first of all my
parents had a very,
very like specific
political views about China.
My dad grew up in Taiwan.
My mom left main land China just
as the communist government
was coming to power.
So they have very specific views.
And Superman was supposed
to be about truth,
justice and the American way.
So what does that mean to have a
character representing those three
things in China?
In modern China, in
modern China right?
And I just was like man that's --
I'm going to get so much
hate mail if I do that.
I do not want to do it.
And then I get called then
to DC Comics Burbank offices.
I have this hour long
meeting with Jim Lee.
I'm a huge Jim Lee fan.
Boy, like I said I
grew up on his comics.
I don't even remember what he said.
I just stared at his
face for like an hour.
>> Petra Mayer: I know
I met him too.
>> Gene Luen Yang: And at the end.
>> Petra Mayer: And I was like.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Petra Mayer: No.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
Exactly like that.
With the finger to my lips.
And then at the end I'm
like okay let's do it.
>> Petra Mayer: It's true --
now that I, I mean I read the
first three issues and it's true,
there's no equivalent so
far in the comics of truth,
justice and the American way.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah like.
>> Petra Mayer: Not really.
>> Gene Luen Yang: What we --
so, so one of the things that you
know I teach at Hamlin University.
I teach creative writing
to mostly adult students.
And one of the things I tell my
students is whatever you're scared
of as a writer just run
at it as hard as you can.
So because that was what scared me
about this Chinese Superman project,
I just decided to run at
it as hard as I could.
So in the first story arc which
takes place in the first six issues,
the bad guys are the Freedom
Fighters of China were fighting
for truth, justice and democracy.
So it's about how the
new Superman reacts
to these supposed super villains.
>> Petra Mayer: I still have to say,
not to put too fine a point upon it,
cannot -- Kenan Kong is a jerk.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
Kenan Kong is a major jerk.
He's, he's a .
>> Petra Mayer: He's not Clark Kent.
>> Gene Luen Yang: No
he's not Clark Kent.
>> Petra Mayer: He's
not mild mannered.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah, he,
he starts off as a bully.
And the inspiration behind that is
actually from two different sources.
One is American.
Most of you probably have
not read Superman's stories
from the 1930's and 40's.
But Clark Kent started
off as a jerk wad.
He was a major, major jerk.
In the 30's and 40's he
would beat people up and then
after he was done beating them up
hew would like sermonize at them.
He would do really cruel things.
He would take these slum
lords and leave them
on a desert island
to starve to death.
And he would never
come back for them.
He would just let, let that happen.
>> Petra Mayer: I think there's
actually a tumbler called superman
is a jerk.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Petra Mayer: Or
something like that.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Exactly.
>> Petra Mayer: Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: And
it's all from like.
>> Petra Mayer: Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
the 30's and 40's.
>> Petra Mayer: Golden
age Superman where.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Petra Mayer: He's
being a complete jerk.
>> Gene Luen Yang: So, so Clark
Kent himself actually went
through this moral development,
as the, as the decades went on.
We wanted, we wanted
the Chinese Superman
to have the same moral development.
The second thing is I'm
hugely influenced by the story
of the Monkey King, which
is Journey to the West.
It's a.
>> Petra Mayer: Right.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Classic.
>> Petra Mayer: Plays a large part
in American Born Chinese, which.
>> Gene Luen Yang: It does.
>> Petra Mayer: I think
is fantastic.
You guys should all read it.
>> Gene Luen Yang: The
Monkey King also starts off
as this major jerk off.
What, what Journey to the West is
about is the Monkey King's
spiritual journey going
from selfishness to selflessness.
So Kenan is going to
make that same journey.
>> Petra Mayer: I also
was interested in --
I read an interview where you
talked about picking his name.
Which puts [inaudible].
>> Gene Luen Yang: Oh my gosh.
>> Petra Mayer: You guys
probably know that people
in the Superman universe have
alliterative names like Lex Luthor,
Leven Lang etcetera, etcetera.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
You know Chinese names
are super hard.
It's like ridiculously hard.
I, I have an acquaintance who is
a Mandarin high school teacher.
And she was like it takes
me three weeks to come
up with my students
names it's so hard.
Because there're aren't like
defaults you can go to right?
And in the original -- so
this is the controversy.
The original name -- like
this is what I wanted.
I wanted something that
started with the K sound to, to,
to kind of mirror Clark Kent.
Two is I wanted it to be immediately
pronounceable by an American reader.
And a, and just having
that combination was
incredibly, incredibly difficult.
I don't, I don't even think we
got it right because Kenan is
like most people would
pronounce it Keenan in America.
But at least it's pronounceable
enough.
>> Petra Mayer: What do the
syllables actually mean?
I know they actually
have some kind of.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah,
they, they have meaning.
So, so Kong they're actually
only two common Chinese surnames
that start with the K sound.
It's Kang and Kong.
Kang is a bad guy in the Marvel
universe so we went with Kong.
And then the second one the,
the Kenan part it's two words.
The first one means to overcome,
which I we felt like was appropriate
for a Superman character.
And the second nan means south.
And he's from Shanghai.
People in Beijing call people
from Shanghai southerners.
>> Petra Mayer: I'm a word
building junky so that kind
of detail like so exciting to me.
This is not the first super
hero comic you've done.
There was the Shadow Hero.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Petra Mayer: Which
is sort of -- there --
sort of an origin story right?
For a, for a forgotten
silver age super hero.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
Yeah Golden Age actually.
>> Petra Mayer: Golden Age ooh.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Golden Age -- so.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Gene Luen Yang: I, I learned
from the internet as you do
with these sorts of things.
But, but in the 1940's there
was a character by the name
of The Green Turtle
and he is not awesome.
He has a terrible suit like he has
a cowl and a cape and no shirt.
That's what he looks like okay?
And he's kind of a, a
Batman knock off as well.
He operates out of a turtle cave.
He drives a turtle plane.
But there is one fascinating
thing about him and that is
that the rumor is he might be the
first Chinese-American Superhero.
His creator was a guy
named Chu Hing who was one
of the first Asian-American
to be working the American
comic book industry.
And the rumor about The Green Turtle
is that Chu wanted his character
to be Chinese-American
like he himself was,
but his publishers
wouldn't let him do it.
Because they didn't think
that a Chinese-American
superhero would sell
in the American marketplace.
So Chu Hing being a cartoonist
gets super passive aggressive
and that's what we do.
That's what cartoonists do.
And he draws these early
Green Turtle comics
that you almost never see his face.
He hides his face in shadow.
He puts like furniture
in front of his face.
He puts other characters
Every -- most of the time
you only see his back right?
And, and the humor is
that he did that so he
and his reader could imagine his,
his hero as a Chinese-American.
Chu Hing never gets around to
telling us the original story
and I thought man this
is like a whole
in the American comic's
history that I want to fill.
So I teamed up with a guy named
Sunny Lu amazingly talented
cartoonist and together
we created a origin story
for this obscure character
from the 1940's
and firmly established
him as a Chinese-American.
>> Petra Mayer: That's
almost like Fanfic.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
It totally is Fanfic.
>> Petra Mayer: Did
you write Fanfic?
>> Gene Luen Yang: We
were able to do it.
We were able to do it
because he's in public domain.
>> Petra Mayer: He is not Fanfic
if you know you have
a platform like that.
But I sort of sort of secretly.
>> Gene Luen Yang: It is Fanfick.
>> Petra Mayer: That's
my head cabin.
Okay cool.
So the nice lady there is telling
me we have 10 minutes left.
So I'm just going to ask you
before we throw to the audience
for questions, what's next?
I know there's another volume
of Secret Coders in the works.
>> Gene Luen Yang: So right
now I'm working on four,
four projects, Secret Coders.
I'm working on the continuation
of Abcar Lesterbender
in graphic novel format.
I'm working on the new Superman.
And the next big project where
I'm doing both the writing
and the drawing is
called Dragon Hoops.
It is my first nonfiction work.
I followed a high school basketball
team out of Oakland for a season
for the 2014 2015 season
and it will be about that.
>> Petra Mayer: Ah
that sounds so cool.
And what are your plans for the
rest of your term as the ambassador
for Young Peoples Literature?
>> Gene Luen Yang:
Well we are ramping
up to do something for the summer.
We really want to a, a, put together
a, a, really full summer program.
We're trying to figure out how
to get the word out about that.
>> Petra Mayer: Cool.
Well thank you so much.
I think it might be time --
do people in the audience
have questions?
Is that a -- do we have
people with microphones?
Here we go.
Hey there's somebody.
>> Hi.
>> Petra Mayer: The
lights are so bright.
>> Hi. This is a very
strange question.
I was analyzing Boxers and Saints
for one of my college classes
on the graphic novel actually.
And I kind of.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
That's kind of awesome.
>> Okay. It kind of was.
And I was kind of really
happy when I saw it
in the syllabus because I'm weird.
I'm rambling.
But so I came up with a theory
about why Saints was very dully
colored except for the visions.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay awesome.
>> I'm curious if I came
up with the right reason.
So why did you do that?
>> Gene Luen Yang: I
thought you were going
to tell me your reason first.
>> My theory was because Joan
of Arc's visions were
supposedly in gold.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Wow .
Okay that's kind of,
that's kind of it.
That's kind of it.
That awesome.
First of all thank you for doing
homework about one of my comics.
I really appreciate that.
Boxers and Saints is a
two volume graphic novel
about the Boxer Rebellion,
the good guys on one side
and bad guys on the other.
The first volume Boxers I
wanted to be about heroism.
So I looked at heroic
storytelling traditions,
like American Super Hero
comics and like Chinese opera.
So it's brightly colored
it's really long.
It's really sad.
Kind of the way Chinese opera is.
And then the second
volume I wanted it to be
about sainthood, saintliness.
And, and, and regardless of
what faith or tradition you come
from whether it's eastern or
western saintliness is always tied
in with humility.
So I wanted that book to seem much
more humble than the first one.
That's why it's shorter.
That's why it's dully colored.
I actually was fighting
for my publisher
to print it on like cheaper paper.
But they would not let me do that
which is probably a good idea.
Which is probably a good idea but
that, that, that was the thinking.
But, but what, what you were
noticing was actually the Joan
of Arc sequences we wanted to
model after illuminated manuscripts
from like you know
old school Europe.
And that's what, that's
what you were seeing right?
So.
>> Petra Mayer: Ah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: It looks much
more like illuminated manuscript
if it's set against a dull tone.
>> Petra Mayer: I think we have
time for two more questions.
So step up.
>> So how does American
Born Chinese relate
to like your experiences
and if it does like.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Well
first thank you for --
I'm assuming you read
American War Chinese.
>> Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Thank
you for reading it.
American Born Chinese
is a work of fiction
but I definitely pulled really
heavily from my own life to,
to write that book especially the
middle story line about Jin Wang,
that Chinese American
kid who's growing
up in a predominately
white neighborhood.
I pulled heavily from my
late elementary school years
and my, and my junior high.
Especially junior high.
Junior high was when I experiment--
experienced the most explicit racism
because people in junior high
including me are jerks, right?
Anybody who has gone through
junior high you know that.
But thank you.
Thank you for your question.
>> Thank you.
>> I'll be quick, it's
not a question.
It's a compliment.
I'm a middle school
language arts teacher
and over the years I've built a
pretty extensive personal classroom
library for my students.
And Boxers and Saints is
the most stolen text out of.
>> Gene Luen Yang: That is.
>> Petra Mayer: That's
a great accolade.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
>> Petra Mayer: Ah can we
take one more question.
No we're done?
Oh one more.
Okay.
>> Hello. First of all I want to say
I've read all you books and Boxers
and Saints is probably my
favorite graphic novel of all time.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
Oh wow, thank you.
Thank you.
That's really gratifying to hear.
Because that took six like eight
six years of my life that book.
But thank you.
Thank you so much.
>> I wanted to know what
made you decide to take the,
to take the Boxer Rebellion and
create it into a graphic novel?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Well I, I,
I didn't really know that much
about the Boxer Rebellion
when I started that project.
I grew up in a Chinese-American
Catholic community.
And in the year 2000 Pope
John Paul II canonized a group
of Chinese catholic saints.
So from my home church this
was like a big, big deal.
They like freaked out about it.
They had all sorts of special
masses and celebrations,
there were like egg
rolls everywhere.
Anytime you see like
giant trays of egg rolls
around Chinese people they're
really happy about something.
And, and, and I, I was inspired
by these, these festivities.
I looked in the lives of these
canonized saints and discovered
that they were mostly a lot
of them were martyred
during the Boxer Rebellion.
And they were martyred specifically
back then if you were Chinese
and you were -- you like embraced
any sort of western faith,
you were seen as somebody who
turned her back on her culture.
So the more I read about the
Boxer Rebellion the more I felt
like it mirrored this tension that
I had felt between the two halves
of myself as an Asian-American.
Between these eastern
and western halves.
So I really went in I mean it
was it was a little bit selfish.
It was a little bit like
looking in the mirror.
I really went in wanting to
understand the tension in myself.
>> Okay. Okay, thank you.
>> Gene Luen Yang: But thank you.
Thank you for that question.
>> Petra Mayer: Alright.
Thank you.
Oh we can take two more?
Okay we can take two more.
Yay.
>> Hello.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Hi.
>> I read American Born Chinese in
college part of my identity class.
Do you have any advice for
Asian-American people on how
to write, sort of writing things
that everybody would like and also
about Asian comments and culture?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay
you're asking advice
for Asian-American writers.
Are you an Asian-American writer?
>> Yes.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Awesome.
Awesome. Well, well first as a --
just for writers in general I
think one of the things you have
to realize is your self doubt and
fear is just never going to go away.
You know it will always be there
no matter, no matter what you do.
So you just have to
hug it like a friend.
You know? And, and just
recognize it will always be there.
As an Asian-American I would say
in general there's this really
weird thing that happens
where is you give deep
into your own experience.
If you get specific it
suddenly becomes universal.
You know what I mean?
It's like a, it's like
this really weird thing.
The more specific you get the
more details, you, you lend,
the more authentic your
experience becomes.
And the more universal
appeal it has.
So get over, get over the fear.
And then go deep and specific.
That would be my advice.
>> Thank you.
>> So I wanted to ask
whether the Sun Wokong part
of American Born Chinese
actually follows the story line
of Journey to the West?
>> Gene Luen Yang: The -- okay
the Sun Wukong part of Journey
to the West or of American
Born Chinese deviates.
>> Oh.
>> Gene Luen Yang: It deviates.
I really hope that American Born
Chinese is not your only exposure
to Journey to the West because that
book is mind blowing and amazing.
There's a reason why you know
Chinese people have been reading
that book for 500 years.
When I first started doing comics
as an adult I wanted to do some kind
of adaption of the
Monkey King stories simply
because I have a deep, deep
childhood attachment to it.
And originally I was going
to do a straight adaptation,
but then I realized almost
every working cartoonist
in China had done a straight
adaptation and they're all better
than anything I could do.
So I set aside that idea and
eventually the way I came back
to it I realized I'm going to use
the Monkey King story as a way
of talking about the
Chinese-American experience.
Because none of those Chinese
artists could do that, right?
And that's why I deviated.
I deviated in ways that
I felt like would bring
in you know American
aspects to the story.
>> Alright, thank you.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Thank you.
>> Petra Mayer: And thank
you everyone for coming out
and thank you for those
really thoughtful questions.
You've been a wonderful
and very patient audience.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah, thank you.
>> Petra Mayer: Thank
you to Gene Yang.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Thank
you for coming out.
>> Petra Mayer: And out -- and just
so you know you'll be signing right?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Petra Mayer: He'll
be signing downstairs.
I've been told line
four on the lower level.
So.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yep.
Line four on the lower level.
>> Petra Mayer: Yep.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Alright.
>> Petra Mayer: Thank you.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Thank you.
>> Petra Mayer: All very, very much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.